right new game this time of black here
do quwain or something from from the
United States so on okay let's mix in a
Sicilian here just playing on the open
Sicilian surprising is some pretty high
rated but play some pretty dreadful set
up here against this the specific line
this inertia text set up is just not not
very good against this disc on con line
you fire her so I can just grab it right
so um yeah I want to pawn you might play
Bishop f4 trying to arrest my queen so
what should I do I mean I can just maybe
retreat to to c7 potentially go to a
five or take on c3 still some tricks
here okay he doesn't want his pawn
structure to be a to be demolished on c3
but I can just down just develop now and
I mean it's just just a central pawn he
might get some some some stuff going
here with g 4 and so on but it's a
central pawn
yeah and also this a3 move might be
handy with before before to come okay
maybe you wants to play f5 it's a
possibility question is some is it a
problem also yeah well I've never cannot
take because g5 is hanging I don't want
to play g5 if it looks like a weakness
okay but I can I could play not to be
six here with night c4 that's an idea
which only drawback is i cannot use it
be porn then but still looks good yeah
should i go nite c4 or false yeah i can
do prep move first f5 is not not an
issue and also I'm now realizing maybe
92 a 5 it's also an idea knight Knight
e5 to see for could could be in could be
you could be in a tiara I try that
I mean one problem is if I whatever i do
not see for captures and this Bishop is
not doing much and I don't want to
recapture the pawn really so this
doesn't help taking on default Bishop
before as what white ones so maybe this
is some this is good nights you for it's
quite aggressive maybe even intending to
sacrifice on b2 and over a three or
something and he might need to give up
both bishops yeah like that you still
need some wanted to move to to get
something really going here like h5 g6
and still the tool and it's not not made
or something okay night to see forum
what's the idea I could have thought
about the other one really okay but this
shouldn't be bad yeah okay take here
then maybe at five then maybe a five but
of course he needs to I mean I can maybe
try to start already with our sacrifices
now takes on be to take Sonia could take
me to really
yeah come on ideas night be to King
takes Bishop a three maybe f6 ya f
signal f six second take a 3 this is
complete nonsense so this was the idea
and now a five was my voice my plan a5
a4 i also have Quinn before check at
some point let's try this a 4 is really
a huge threat I mean maybe the sacrifice
isn't the the best movie on
mathematically speaking but I don't want
him to have all the funny with the
attack so now i'm at least on have some
some play on my own i did so much its
may be quite dangerous
you came I didn't expect that really but
maybe it's maybe it's not so bad okay i
cannot i need to give check here and
what now well Bishop c5 I always have
this check so should I should have even
considered to just take i think i just
take to get rid of this attacking porn
which might play f6 or whatever and now
i have maybe bishop e6 also at some
point we should be six and if the bishop
moves on d5 g4 Bishop c5 hours ssnlf
this is intermediate check so i don't
lose the exchange the next move could be
look to see ya so I guess check now
right so yeah check and and rook c8
oh wait Queen to e5 I need to pay
attention to this could be a quite
embarrassing yeah I need to I need to
prevent this first so while kg 7 is
hanging so route c8 winning a tempo and
what now rookie to attacking c2 and yeah
you might have worked to simply ff4 with
Bishop f5 time morning yeah this taking
him taking yourself as a nuisance
okay i need to play move at some point
how do i what could can I do
okay I try I try this idea Bishop f5
problem is he might take in play Bishop
age 82 and then I made on Justin's made
on g7 okay it's playing a solid move
first look here the route before p5 as a
threat ah-huh maybe let's still has some
life in this position what is he doing
now Fredrik be three now
it's checkmate rookie ain't no maybe
this wasn't bad after all hard to say I
can we can check and queen have six this
is made really maybe it doesn't see it
ruki eight is just wish I know I can
take it yet I can take yet here I tend
to age five check check check white
[ __ ] wow this was very lucky very lucky
of course but quite a fun end and I and
hair absolutely midst calculated
everything at the end Wow funny so what
is this I mean ok computer gives this is
winning so I played here yeah the thing
is I can just take on b3m I can just
take but why is this winning i'm not
seeing it I mean it's winning a piece
yeah what I didn't see is I can I can I
can go here just attorney to ok I didn't
have much time I was only seeing rookie
at media and this I thought I overlooked
that the Queen now is prettiest covering
this and queen here King here so when im
a piece up and for mating a check also
somehow so wow so i really i really got
got quite simply here computer gives me
slight advantage I thought I was while I
wasn't sure and this is really winning
Roxy five wins from like cool ok then to
to show this now know what can win
yeah just as he did in the game this is
winning now but he didn't manage she
spent two too much time and has had five
seconds seconds left so okay quite an
entertaining game lots of mistakes but I
guess I hope fun to watch thanks for
watching